and if you end up by your damn self that
says something about you like it's not
you not sport because it's not today's
women's fault yeah I'm not even blaming
no one who's here today it's not your
fault but you gotta understand yeah that
women have had a loud voice in terms of
dating in terms of your standards your
expectations who you want what you want
what you aspire to want men have heard
it all we've heard it all from childhood
we've heard it all and I'm not saying
it's you because you were a kid with us
but we have heard it all and here's the
thing I think men as a result of this
are far more in tune with the wants of
women than women always the real wants
of men because we had the same voice
you've had that's why we know you better
that's why we game you the way we do
because we know because men know whether
you're a winner or a loser the guy who
gets all the girls and the guy who gets
no girls they both understand your
nature do you get it I agree they both
get you you had to bro yeah where is you
don't get us because you get cheated on
you go let me see what that [ __ ] looks
like yeah I feel like women don't listen
they don't learn right they will just
they will have things happen and then
repeat the Cycles it's always someone
else's fault no but that's why I said
the accountability that's why I say if
you get cheated on it's your own fault
take accountability
um
when I got cheated I know why it wasn't
oh how did why did he do this to me I
know it was what I was doing in the
relationship yeah I can't I believe yeah
yeah but there are a lot of women that
don't which I understand they just can't
that's a lack of maturity
yeah it's not even maturity there's a
lot of old women who are still
delusional here like it's I think that's
the issue with the dating market right
now is that most women are absolutely
delusional in the sense that everyone
thinks they're a prize doesn't matter
how many kids you got how many guys
you've been through everyone thinks
they're there I mean I mean five foot
two waitresses who sit sit beside me in
a dating table and ask me to prove
myself to them now I'm looking at them
everyone knows and I think what's tough
about being a woman is they to learn the
hardware in it they'll have to learn
slowly yeah well that's why the the
largest growing homeless population is
women because if and this is the thing a
lot of women are banking on government
handouts and you don't know if those
will ever go away in the UK or the US
one day they could be gone like that and
if that happens and you don't have 2.5
million to retire you're on the streets
so I can ask a question not based on
that because I said interest in stuff
when we're talking about men wanting to
obviously earn more than females and we
were discussing earlier about women
being more empowered to working Etc
where does that sit with men so looking
at the start of women are becoming
homeless because they don't they haven't
sorted out to make sure that they have
something they're relying on men that
they're not eligible for therefore they
think it's fine to just laze around and
rely on a man because for me personally
I wouldn't rely on a man fully
financially or a woman for that fact I I
wouldn't do that just because well for
two reasons one I like the feeling of
being able to gift and provide but it
doesn't mean that I wouldn't allow them
to also treat me or be the one that
spends more but women just think that
they don't need to work because why why
don't you need to work you know what it
is and I said doesn't there is an energy
and a um
energy there's a psychology that comes
along with a lot of women who are
successful Okay and like I said a lot of
women who have become successful within
the corporate world specifically have
had to become more masculine just to get
ahead because it's in a male-dominated
world okay so you've had to become more
masculine and you've made more money and
you've become this shock you've become
this tiger right yeah there's not I
totally understand why you've got you
you've had to do that
if you go to a man with that energy it's
game over not the man you'd respect yeah
that's the point that the man you'd
respect that doesn't mean you don't
become submissive to your man though a
lot of women find it hard to do because
they because those degrees that money
that boss chick mentality becomes their
Persona you know I mean they embody that
I'm a boss I'm a [ __ ] I'm it's like no
man wants to deal with that for real you
can also be run You're vulnerable You're
you're still dedicated to your partner
you can still be and allow yourself to
rest because that's one thing for me I'm
as I said extremely successful well to a
degree and sometimes I just wanna I
don't want to have to do that all the
time so it's nice to be looked after
when you're someone who's always bossing
it bossing it having to do everything to
be able to come home and have that meal
cooked be picked up be treated
wait a minute wait a minute who's
cooking your meal when you get home I
was just about to say because that's not
submissive
yeah to be looked after that's a treat
um
no but what I will say is that I enjoy
being submissive in a relationship I
feel like if I can't be in my whole
feminine energy and feel like I am the
female in the relationship when I come
home regardless what I'm doing on my on
a professional basis if I can't be that
then somewhat you're missing a little
bit of masculine within you that doesn't
Jam say you like I feel like I'm not a
woman allows women who are masculine
choose feminine men
yeah
one at a time sorry go on you guys sorry
um I said they can only get feminine man
because any masculine dudes me and my
boys like we can't even see the
masculine women like they only one woman
complained to me about men it's always
rather masculine women comparing about
very logical issues which always shows
to me you're dating feminine dudes and
the reason that and feminine dudes is
none of the top guys are having it and
when you say Feminine by the way you
don't necessarily mean effemina yeah
because those feminine men don't know
they don't always know their feminine
men you get
yeah their results are glaringly obvious
but they don't know that's who they are
and you know what I'll say a lot of
women have and a lot of men have
substituted masculinity for aggression
thank you so they think that the most
aggressive man or the most you don't
masturbate they think that's masculinity
while that is masculine energy the guy
can't put nothing together right he
doesn't know how to manage his finances
he doesn't know how to manage a house
but the thing is what he can do is
display masculinity because like I said
women are attracted to men women can get
turned on by two men fighting right
that they never get turned on by two men
fighting right and that because they are
displaying their masculine energy they
don't mean the guy knows how to deal
with the finances in the home and you
see when you talk about and you see when
you talk about a man who grows up into
the sort of man who maybe doesn't have a
full arsenal of coping skills as well
right yeah here's the thing I find
really interesting right when women end
up as single moms half my family that's
this that's their situation I don't
judge that's not what I'm here for but
what I'll say half the time when that
situation happens
there's the whole I was young it was a
mistake shouldn't judge me shouldn't
blame me these things happen all right
cool yeah but then you see if it goes
wrong and the dad's not in the pitch or
typically whatever
that son who then grows up without that
Dad
you know the women his age when he grows
up they make no allowances for the
deficit in his development as a result
of the dad that these same women will
also say in the same argument
it's not that deep because it's like I
was only a mistake it's not that deep we
we more women can do it by yourself now
these days anyway like there's all these
arguments why it's like it's not that
big a deal but then those boys they grew
up as affected men you know yeah and
women don't make no allowances for men
like that they get left on the shelf
right but the thing is those men are the
men that women are like I said those
those hyper aggressive can't do anything
outside of just be aggressive men right
are the men that women get attracted to
and then when those men act like
children yeah right because that's what
they are they're grown children right oh
these men no yes no you chose that guy
you chose that grown child well it's
because the same the same traits that
make the guy the hero make him the
villain and so so the reason like a lot
of girls they're girls that stay for
years with a man that abused them and
you're thinking like why on Earth why on
Earth would you do that a lot of times
they don't mention that she was also
abusing him too because most abusive
relationships are Mutual a lot of times
they they forget that part but you
wonder like why is she staying well it's
because she knows that if he can beat me
up he can protect me
and it's a weird biological function but
we can't help what we're attracted to
um can I ask a quick question
um who is more likely to cheat the
masculine male or the feminine male
that's good effeminate no they're
masculinity
because it's because he's got more women
that are attracted to him what about the
feminine male being slightly more
vulnerable or weaker so therefore
they're more yeah I'm just wondering you
know what my take is I feel like the
feminine guy it just as likely would but
he can't that bit that's what I was
going to say
let me read a stat quickly though this
is interesting 43.7 of cheating women
and 22.2 percent of cheating men have
cheated with this cheated on their
spouse with somebody that they both know
that they both know is she looking real
sad
so women cheat more foreign
with men or with people that both of
both her and her spouse know can I ask a
question is that so I'm looking at you
is that because they want it to hurt
more is is anyone think that that's why
because it hurts more if I'm looking
interesting
from what I know usually it's a case of
the people around you are the people
that you spend the most time with and
it's where the relationships especially
for women will develop yeah and that's
how you create an emotional attachment
from time spent with the person and
therefore the statistics would be higher
with people that you know that you'd be
cheating with there was a there was a
video out the other day that went viral
with a girl coming home to her man and
her she was in um her man was in bed
with her mother you see that yeah yeah
she said see that one
what did she say to her daughter she's
like you about taking care of it yes you
weren't taking care of him no yeah yeah
yeah and the mom is living in her house
no Mama's living in the house yeah we
are dancing
like a lot of people are cheating with
people that people both know
earlier on in this conversation yeah I
believe generally we agreed unanimously
that when it comes time to sex that
for women
generally more emotion is attached to
that sort of decision yeah so
I don't know if I'm reaching now but I'm
just thinking like
like if men are less emotionally LED
with who they sleep with then maybe
there's less consideration for those for
those men who the women are cheating
with because those men are they care
less they care less about who they sleep
with whereas women care about who more
they sleep with so it doesn't surprise
me that a higher amount of men
it doesn't surprise me that women would
have slept with a higher amount of men
that are like crazy because they're
familiar it's like how would you do that
that's crazy but then that's maybe
because
the men in question are not as concerned
yeah as the women are hence why the men
are sleeping with a far less percentage
of women that they both know
do you think cyber sex cyber whatever
they call it is cheating yeah yeah I've
watched like if you if you don't
actually meet the person but you have
yeah if you have no it might not just be
called it might be someone that you met
on a app and you guys decide to have I
think to me
either way that's your time to leave bro
is that cheating that's still never met
them I think as a girl I could I think I
could more get past something like that
more than physical cheating but it's
still cheating
I might just give it a blah but maybe we
can do it together
on the screen no I don't know you need
help you're on the screen you're on a
screen with somebody I think I could
understand more than you you went and
physically touched somebody that's the
only fan stuff like only no that's
different that's like corn so that's
different you actually yeah it's
engaging so are you talking about just
witnessing as in corn or talking about
engaging with them
engagement for me is
no engagements futile so once you've
engaged in
um discussions of a sexual nature or
you've gone over the boundary of where
the the conversation is PC or flirting
so if we're saying flirting is cheating
how could we possibly then say that
level of now that's an intimate act that
you're doing whether or not it's on a
screen or not is totally irrelevant
you've gone into sexual act with the
person just because it's cyber doesn't
mean I mean we're getting into Black
Mirror territory here but you know um
you know I to me that's not that's not
appropriate I have a question has
anybody caught someone cheating in a
crazy way
foreign
I've caught one of my
friends Partners cheating oh wow it
wasn't one of my how
um it wasn't crazy but I sit like in a
club it's a classic in a club scenario
they saw me they thought they could duck
out it's too late bro like
you looked me in my eye like I see you
hey how are you how's your mum like
listen we're here now
that scenario is crazy because depending
on how well you know I actually knew
both of them quite well you then are in
this Paradox of what do you do with this
information that you've got do you go
call your mate and excuse me
[Laughter]
fair enough yeah it's a very difficult
it's a very difficult
um in that scenario it was very
difficult for me to know how to navigate
the situation because I also knew the
partner quite well and then you'll start
with this sort of where does your
loyalty lie just stay out of it what I
did was then address the partner I'm
like listen here's what we're gonna do
we all know what's going on here so you
you're gonna have to let them know
either you're about to tell me you're in
an open relationship and I'll step out
your business or I'm not comfortable
with just pretending that I didn't see
that so I'm going to give you the
opportunity to go tell them otherwise I
might snitch on you I don't want to have
to do that because I don't want to be in
your business but you've done it clearly
it wasn't agreed because you tried to
run so you know you're then in that
thing of I you gonna speak or am I gonna
have to do it for you which is going to
make it a lot worse
if I have to tell them do you think for
the guys for the guys here do you think
it's different like if we saw one of our
guys cheating
and women saw one of their one of their
girls cheating
do you think it's different like or if
or for instance if I saw D if I saw one
if you if I saw your girl cheating I
would say it's more likely for a guy to
tell his guy bro your girl then it is
for a woman to say you know what your
man was as many any of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible